it opened
that's a first welcome back to the
things
are you wondering what direction frozen
3 could take we're imagining how it
would look if disney got twisted
and gave us evil anna after elsa turned
into the fifth spirit at the end of
frozen two and retreated to the
enchanted forest
anna became the new queen of arendelle
but without her big sister's guidance
anna went down the wrong path sick and
tired of always living in elsa's ice
power shadow
anna discovered fire powers of her own
and the destruction she caused
like melting poor olaf earned her a new
title
the evil queen of arendelle disney
villains
watch out there's a new baddie ready to
steal the show
and melt everything that gets in her way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you